[Music]  miron morris is a married woman it was  perfect the rich singer has said I do  too longtime love Ryan heard after he  pops the question in July of 2017  my family has a little lake house in  Michigan where I was raised and kind of  went out in a little rowboat get away  from everybody kind of when the Sun was  going down felt like if you meant it you  must have meant it if I heard proposed  with a stunning and unique diamond ring  custom-made for Morris the stone is from  New York City it's like an uncut diamond  and then the rest of its just like cast  just custom for her because I didn't I  don't know I couldn't like just buy  something to make it something oh I saw  I mean it was so emotional and so  perfect he's a very thoughtful human  being and I feel like the proposal was  just as thoughtful as he always says  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]